so one of the brilliant things designers
do is produce designs they can also help
you with one of the other more important
parts of the process which is choosing
between those designs from Jonathan what
are some best practices for making
decisions between designs using user
feedback sure I like to think of it as
three sort of different general areas of
your designs when you're thinking about
how to structure your app or your
website so we have information
architecture which is sort of the way
that things are structured and the sort
of the flow there's also interaction
design which is you know whether or not
it's easy to find a button on your page
or your app and then there's also the
design element or the the visual design
the visual design allows a user to give
feedback on you know the appeal or the
color scheme or other elements within
your design so thinking of it in these
three general areas gives you sort of
the ability to serve ask the questions
that you want to get good feedback from
your design okay so as an example we had
you know feedback in our original paper
prototype that you know our structure
was confusing users couldn't actually
check things off and that would be an
information architecture and then we
also had feedback that you know the
frequent action button was good size and
so that would be like interaction design
exactly and then we also had feedback
that our check boxes were hard to find
or not visually appealing and so that
would be visual design correct yeah all
those elements combined together I think
are essentially the concept or some
experts call the conceptual design but
all of those aspects are fundamental to
the design of your app and you want to
be thinking about all three as you are
developing your your app okay so let's
say we've got a designer who's given us
you know two different visual designs
for an element let's say they've given
us a button that is designed one way and
a button they design another way how
would we go about using user research to
choose between those sure so you can do
two types of studies one you can run
through
a group of users of two or three users
where you show button a then you show a
button beat and you ask for them to
provide feedback on that set then in a
separate study you can do it for a
separate group of users showing button
be then button a you can compare notes
from both of those studies to find out
which is the best button to use and
users tend to prefer the one they see
first generally or the one they see last
generally or is it not as clear as all
that it's not always that clear and
simple oftentimes you want to get in a
user's initial reactions but showing
them close together really helps give
them a visual cue to telling you whether
or not it's something they really enjoy
okay one of the things we just use this
example was you know there's a button a
and there's button be what happens if
the designer gives you five or ten
button designs do we do you still test
all those at once or new test just two
at a time yeah that's a great question I
think it's really important to be
thinking about can the user achieve what
they're intended what you're intending
them to achieve with your design so it
can be 10 buttons or can be 15 buttons
but can they achieve what the intended
task or objective is with your designs
so if the designer presents you with
many different buttons it may be helpful
just to kind of trim it down a little
bit but if you have that many buttons in
order to achieve the intended task you
may still need to test on all those
buttons being available there so it
sounds like it's best to compare these
buttons in separate studies it also
sounds like it's best to think about all
three levels of design when you're
thinking about alternate signs for your
lap yeah that's right and I think you
sort of hit the nail on the head when
you say thinking about all three levels
thinking about all three levels really
encompasses the heart or the concept or
the cot the conceptual design aspect of
your app you should really be doing
something that enables a user to do
something that they love to do and
that's really the heart
effect of your app something that I
always really enjoy talking about to hmm
awesome thank you again for coming in I
appreciate it thank you